vamos a resolver en esta ocasión un
problema bastante interesante lo primero
que quiero que se den cuenta es que
tengo dos funciones aquí la función y es
igual a equis y esta función es igual a
x cuadrado a menudo se x cuya gráfica es
esto de amarillo ahora lo que voy a
querer es girar en la región que está
entre estas dos funciones alrededor de
la recta de igual a 4 y por lo tanto me
va a quedar un sólido de revolución el
cual ya dibujé aquí en adelante un poco
en la gráfica para no perder tanto
tiempo en hacerla mientras hacemos el
vídeo pero mira es justo como una vasija
si te das cuenta una vasija cuya base
está aquí abajo y después tenemos su
boca al final de este sólido de
revolución ahora la pregunta este vídeo
es cómo encuentro el volumen de esta
vasija que yo tengo aquí y adivinen qué
método voy a utilizar pues claro voy a
utilizar el método de las arandelas sin
embargo en esta ocasión no voy a girar
alrededor del eje de las x voy a girar
alrededor de la recta y es igual a 4 por
lo tanto voy a dibujar aquí mi
rectángulo y este rectángulo tiene
recuerden de ancho de x
es justo este grosor una de las cosas
más importantes de este método así que
para que no la pierdan de vista la voy a
dibujar aquí en esta gráfica que tengo a
la derecha por lo tanto este va a ser mi
agujero o mío yo de mi moneda que tengo
en la arandela y después tengo una cara
exterior es esta que voy a dibujar aquí
ahí va fíjense y ahora tengo que bajar y
no me está quedando nada mal perfecto y
ya con esto bueno lo primero que quiero
dibujar les es el grosor porque la
arandela tiene un cierto grosor de
grosor de x por lo tanto vamos a darle
un poco de volumen a nuestra arandela
recuerden que era como una moneda con un
hueco en el centro con un agujero en el
centro y ya que tiene aquí un cierto
grosor ahora lo que voy a hacer es
colorear un poco la cara de enfrente
porque porque recuerden que el problema
consiste en sacar el área de esta cara
que estoy sacando aquí por lo tanto
déjenme colorear la de verde ya la
tenemos coloreada y ahora con esto mi
pregunta va a ser como encuentro el área
de esta cara de mirandela pero hasta acá
los escucho su pregunta es porque el
área si lo que tenemos que encontrar es
el volumen bueno porque si nosotros acá
el área de esta cara o de esta base de
la arandela después multiplicamos por el
grosor que es de x y ya encontramos el
volumen por lo tanto la pregunta fuerte
acerca de este problema es cómo
encontramos el área de esto que tenemos
coloreado por lo tanto vamos a buscarla
el área de esta cara de mirandela como
la encontramos bueno primero darse
cuenta que lo que tengo que hacer es
sacar el área de la moneda completa es
decir el área que tengo de mi
circunferencia exterior y esto es por el
radio al cuadrado pero la pregunta es
que radio a bueno por ahorita vamos a
ponerlo como el radio exterior elevado
al cuadrado que es este de aquí ya esto
recuerden que le tenemos que quitar el
agujero de mi moneda es decir la
circunferencia que tengo adentro y para
encontrar su área hay que multiplicar pi
por el radio pero en este caso el radio
interior elevado al cuadrado muy bien
entonces esto es mi menú o este es mi
plan que voy a seguir y mi idea es que
en este vídeo veamos cómo encontrar esta
área para que en el siguiente vídeo
resolvamos esta integral
así que fijémonos primero en el radar
exterior como encontramos el radio
exterior bueno pues el radio exterior es
la distancia que yo tengo pintada de
verde y como la encontramos pues desde
la recta de igual a 4 hasta la función
de igual a x cuadrada menos 2x es decir
hasta la función que exterior que
tenemos hasta acá entonces para
encontrar la distancia entre estas dos
curvas que tengo que hacer tengo que
hacer la diferencia de dos funciones de
qué funciones pues de la función ye
igual a 4 es decir de la recta menos la
función que yo tengo es decir la función
exterior por lo tanto mi radio exterior
va a ser igual a la recta que es igual a
4 - la función exterior
- x cuadrada más 2x esto porque ya lo
multiplique por menos ahora fijémonos
del radio interior el radio interior
tiene o cumple lo mismo es la distancia
de la recta a la función llegó a la
equis y por lo tanto esta distancia la
sacó como la diferencia de la recta
igual a 4 - la función que iguala x es
decir 4 menos x está genial todo esto no
de lujo porque ya con esto tengo el
radio exterior que es 4 - x cuadrada +
2x y por lo tanto lo puedo poner en el
fórmula del área y primero voy a
factorizar api para que solamente ponga
un pie en lugar de 2 ahora dice que
ponga el radio exterior elevado al
cuadrado que es
4 - x cuadrada + 2x todo esto va a
quedar elevado al cuadrado y si sigo
sustituyendo en el fórmula el área
entonces tengo que restarle el radio
interior elevado al cuadrado pero el
radio interior era 4 menos x y todo esto
elevado al cuadrado perfecto ya con esto
tengo la fórmula para encontrar mi área
de mi arandela de la cara de mi arandela
y ojo ya tengo factor izado api y bueno
si esto lo multiplicó por de x entonces
obtengo el volumen y recuerden que lo
que nosotros hacíamos era tomar la suma
de todas estas arandelas en el intervalo
que nosotros queremos y después tomarme
el límite cuando de x era muy pero muy
pequeño y por lo tanto me tomaba el
integral ahora lo que hay que fijarnos
también es en qué intervalo quiero esta
integral y si te das cuenta en lo que
nos estamos fijando ese lente
de estas dos funciones es decir lo que
yo quiero es ver en qué momento la
función de igual a x es igual a la
función x cuadrada menos 2x por lo tanto
vamos a ponerlo como una igualdad para
poder resolverlo la primera función x
tiene que ser igual a la segunda función
que es x cuadrada menos 2x para sacar
los puntos de intersección fíjate que
los puntos de intersección son los
puntos donde estas dos funciones son
iguales y bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer
es pasar esta x del otro lado y me queda
que menos x menos x y entonces aquí me
queda 0 es igual a x cuadrada menos 3x y
resolver esta igualdad es muy sencilla
esto tiene dos soluciones las cuales una
forma para encontrarlas es factorizar
una x es decir x que multiplica a x
menos 3 y si dos cosas multiplicadas son
cero entonces o la primera es cero o la
segunda es cero es decir o x es igual a
cero o x menos 3 es igual a cero y por
lo tanto mi otra solución es x igual a 3
y ya tengo mis dos puntos de
intersección cuando x es 0 y cuando x
straits y por lo tanto ya tengo mis
límites de integración de esta integral
y ya con esto tenemos la expresión del
volumen de la básica que va
encontrar en el siguiente vídeo